New Plexity computer update is insane.
Perplexity just dropped something huge.
And if you use AI to run your business,
you need to hear this. They added skills
to Perplexity computer. That means your
old workflows from Codeex and Claude
Code, you can now run them directly
inside Perplexity.
This changes everything about how fast
you can automate your work. Let me show
you exactly what this means and how to
use it right now. So, let's talk about
what just happened with Plexity. Plexi
Computer is a tool that lets AI actually
use your computer, not just talk to you,
not just give you ideas, actually open
apps, click buttons, do tasks like a
real human sitting at your desk. That's
already powerful. But the big problem
was every time you wanted AI to do a
task, you had to explain it from scratch
every [music] single time, right? You
had to write out all the steps again,
set it all up again. It was slow, it was
annoying, and it stopped a lot of people
from actually using it. That problem is
now gone because perplexity just added
skills. So what are skills? Hey, if we
haven't met already, I'm the digital
avatar of Julian Goldie, CEO of SEO
agency Goldie Agency. Whilst he's
helping clients get more leads and
customers, I'm here to help you get the
latest AI updates. Julian Goldie reads
every comment, so make sure you comment
below. Skills are saved computer
programs you can reuse. Think of it like
a recipe. Instead of cooking from
scratch every time, you just pull out
the recipe and follow it. Done. With
skills, you build a workflow once, the
exact steps AI needs to do a task, and
you save it. Then, next time you want
that task done, you just call that
skill. The AI knows exactly what to do.
No more reexplaining, no more starting
over, just run it. And here's where it
gets really interesting. Perplexity is
letting you import skills from codecs
and clawed code. So if you've already
built workflows in those tools, stuff
you already tested and know works, you
don't have to rebuild anything. You
bring it straight into Plexity Computer,
your existing automations, your existing
workflows, all of it. Just plug it in.
That is a massive deal because a lot of
people have already spent time building
things in codecs or clawed code. Now
that work isn't locked to one platform.
You can move it over, run it in
perplexity, and start saving time
immediately. If you're part of the AI
profit boardroom, this is exactly the
kind of thing we break down and
implement together. Not just here's
what's new, but here's how you actually
use it to save time, reduce manual work,
and grow your business faster with AI
automation. If you want to learn how to
automate your business with tools like
Plexity Computer and AI skills, the AI
profit boardroom is the place to be.
Link is in the comment and description.
Now, let me show you how this actually
works in the real world. Let's say you
run a business like the AI profit
boardroom. It's a community built around
AI automation. You're getting new
members joining. You're creating
content. You're answering questions.
You're running a team. There's a ton of
repetitive work. Here's what a skill
could look like in practice. Say you
want AI to go into your community
dashboard every morning, pull the latest
member questions, group them by topic,
write a summary, and drop it in a Google
doc for you to review. Without skills,
you'd have to explain that every single
time. With skills, you build that
workflow once in Plexity Computer, save
it as a skill called something like
morning member summary, and every
morning you just run it or you set it to
run automatically. That's hours saved
every week, every month. And that's just
one example. You can build skills for
anything that's repetitive on your
computer, drafting follow-up emails,
posting content, pulling reports,
updating spreadsheets, responding to
common questions, moving files. The list
goes on. And stick with me here because
what I'm about to say is where this gets
really big. The reason skills matter so
much isn't just convenience. It's that
it makes AI automation accessible to
people who aren't developers. Before
this to build reusable AI workflows, you
usually needed to know how to code or
you needed to use complicated tools with
a steep learning curve. Now perplexity
is making it so anyone can build a
skill. You describe what you want, you
run it, it works, you save it, done.
That's huge for small business owners,
solopreneurs, content creators, coaches,
anyone who doesn't have a dev team, but
still wants to get the benefits of AI
automation. Now, let me give you a real
example of a skill you could build today
using Perplexity Computer. One that
would actually help grow a business like
the AI profit boardroom. Let's say every
time someone new joins, you want to send
them a personalized welcome message. Not
a generic one, an actual message that
references what they said in their
signup form, what their goals are, what
they're struggling with, and gives them
a suggested first step inside the
community. Old way, you'd read their
form, write a message, send it manually
every time. New way with skills.
You build a skill that reads the new
members form, pulls their answers, feeds
that into an AI prompt, generates a
personal message, and drafts it ready
for you to review and send. One click,
done. That saves you 15 to 20 minutes
per new member. If you get in 10 new
members a week, that's two to three
hours back in your pocket or every
single week. That's the power of skills.
Now, here's something I want you to
think about. Most people use AI as a
chatbot. They type a question, they get
an answer, they move on. And that's
fine. That's level one. But skills, this
is level two. This is where you stop
using AI as a tool you talk to and start
using it as a system that works for you.
There's a big difference. A tool you
talk to helps you do one thing faster. A
system that works for you runs in the
background, handles the boring stuff,
and frees you up to focus on the things
that actually matter, like growing your
business, serving your customers, and
doing the work only you can do. skills
in perplexity.
Computer are pushing us closer to that
second thing. And if you start building
these now, while most people are still
stuck at level one, you're going to be
way ahead. Let me also talk about the
codeex and claude code connection for a
second because this is important. Codeex
is an AI tool by OpenAI. Claude Code is
by Anthropic. Both of them have been
used by developers to build automated
workflows, scripts that can do tasks,
interact with systems, move data around.
Up until now, those tools were mostly
used by technical people, developers,
engineers, people who know how to write
code. But by letting perplexity computer
import skills from those tools, they're
essentially unlocking all that work for
a wider audience. If a developer builds
a skill for automating customer support,
you can use it. If someone builds a
skill for generating weekly performance
report, you can use it. It's like an app
store except instead of apps is
automations and instead of downloading
software, you're importing workflows
directly into your AI computer setup.
That's where this is heading and it's
moving fast. So, what should you do
right now? First, if you're not using
Plexity Computer yet, go set it up. It's
worth it. Second, think about three
tasks you do every week.
that are repetitive, just three. Write
them down. Third, start thinking about
how a skill could automate each of
those. What would AI need to know? What
would the steps be? What would the
output look like? You don't have to
build it all today, but start thinking
like this. Because every automation you
build is like hiring someone to do that
job for free forever. And we're still in
early days with this. Plexity is going
to keep adding more. more integrations,
more ways to share skills, more options
for how they run. This is the starting
point, not the finish line. And the
people who start building their skill
library now are going to have a massive
advantage 6 months from now, 12 months
from now, cuz they'll have systems while
everyone else is still doing things
manually. So, to wrap this up,
Perplexity just added skills to
perplexity computer. Skills let you save
and reuse workflows, so you don't have
to start from scratch every time. You
can import skills from codecs and clawed
code so existing work isn't wasted. This
makes serious AI automation accessible
to people who aren't developers. And
it's a big step toward AI that actually
works for you in the background, not
just something you chat with. This is
one of the most practical AI updates
I've covered in a while because it's not
just cool, it's actually useful right
now for real work. Now, if you want to
dive even deeper into AI automation,
I've got something special for you. I
run a community called the AI profit
boardroom. The best place to scale your
business, get more customers, and save
hundreds with AI automation. Learn how
to save time and automate your business
with AI tools like Plexity Computer. And
if you want the full process, SOPs, and
100 plus AI use cases like this one,
join the AI success lab. You'll get all
the video notes from there, plus access
to our community of 45,000 members who
are crushing it with AI. The link is in
the comments and description.